- Welcome back to Understanding
Quantum Information and Computation.
My name is John Watrous and I'm the technical director
for IBM Quantum Education.
This is the third lesson of the series. In the first two lessons, we talked about the basics
of quantum information.
First for single systems in isolation and then for multiple systems.
We also discussed standard
basis measurements and unitary operations in both the single and
multiple system settings.
In this lesson, we'll introduce
the quantum circuit model, which gives us a standard way to describe quantum computations,
and we can also use quantum circuits to describe quantum protocols and other sorts of interactions involving multiple quantum devices.
In addition to quantum circuits, we'll also discuss some
important mathematical concepts connected with quantum information,
and we'll use them to observe
a few fundamental limitations on quantum information and what we can do with quantum circuits.
That'll set us up well for
the lesson following this one where we'll see a few
very important examples and that will conclude the
first unit of the series
on the basics of quantum information.
Here's an overview of the lesson. We'll start with the quantum circuit model and we'll see how it works.
Then we'll talk about the
critically important notion of an inner product, as well as orthonormality and projections,
which are connected with inner products. We didn't discuss these things
in the first two lessons, because we really didn't
need to, but now we do.
Inner products provide us
with a mathematical tool that we simply could not do without.
We just would not get far in understanding quantum information and
computation without inner products.
And in the third part of the lesson, we'll take a look at a
few important limitations of quantum information.
Ultimately, what we want to do is to explore interesting
things that we can do with quantum information, but in order to do this effectively,
we need to be aware of some
things that we can't do.
In particular, we'll discuss
the notion of a global phase and why global phases are irrelevant.
We'll see a statement of
the no-cloning theorem, which tells us that quantum states can't be copied in general, and we'll see that two quantum states
can't be perfectly
discriminated from one another unless they're orthogonal, which is a fundamental
limitation to be aware of.
The first topic for the lesson
is the quantum circuit model, which is a model of computation
that provides us with a way
to describe quantum computations.
The quantum circuit model is
based on a more general notion in computer science of a circuit, and you can define many
different models of computation
based on this general notion.
The basic idea is that a
circuit is composed of wires which carry information, and gates, which represent operations
that are applied to the
information carried by the wires.
The term circuit is actually
kind of a strange name to use for this sort of a model
because the word circuit
usually refers to a
circular path of some sort.
But when we talk about circuits
as models of computation, we're usually talking
about acyclic circuits
where circular paths are not allowed.
To be more precise, for the
purposes of this series, we're going to demand that
information always flows from left to right in any circuit.
So if you prefer, you
can think about circuits as describing sequences of operations where time goes from left to right.
Here's an example of a Boolean circuit where the wires carry binary
values, either zero or one,
and the gates represent
Boolean logic operations.
The wires are represented by lines, and here we have two input
bits labeled X and Y,
and if we want to know
what the circuit does on a particular choice of inputs, we propagate the values on
the wires from left to right,
depending on the actions
that the gates have on the values that are
carried by the wires.
So for instance, we can
take a look at what happens when we start out with the top input wire set to the value one and the bottom input wire
set to the value zero.
These two input wires lead
into these two dots right here, which represent fan-out operations, which means that the value is copied
so that it can be carried
forward along multiple wires.
So if we do this, then these
two wires take the value one, which is the same as this one, and these two wires take the value zero,
which is the same as this one.
Here we have a NOT gate which
is indicated by the symbol for logical negation, so the
value that comes out is a zero,
which is the logical negation of one. And similarly, the value
that comes out of this gate is a one which is the
logical negation of zero.
These two gates are AND gates,
this gate is an OR gate, and if we continue on
and propagate the values
through the circuit, evaluating
the gates appropriately, then we see that the final value
on this wire here is a one.
So the entire circuit describes
a sequence of operations that are composed as the figure suggests, and we end up with a function
from two bits to one bit
in this particular case. But in general, there could be any number
of input and output bits.
This particular circuit happens to compute the exclusive OR of the two input bits, so the output is a one
if and only if exactly
one of the two input bits is set to a one and the other one is set to a zero, but that's not really
important, it's just an example.
It's a basic fact about Boolean circuits that any function from any number of bits to any number of bits can be computed
by some Boolean circuit, although sometimes you might
need a very large circuit to compute the function
that you're interested in.
There are other styles that
are used to describe circuits.
For example, this figure
represents exactly the same circuit as we had before, using a style that's perhaps more typical
in electrical engineering, where there are conventions for the shapes that represent different gates.
We aren't going to use
this particular style, but we will introduce
some symbols of our own for different quantum gates, such as Hadamard gates,
Controlled NOT gates,
Toffoli gates, and so on.
Just as an aside, here we can see the origin
of the term circuit.
In the context of electrical engineering, it's very natural to
think about electricity cycling through a circuit.
But in this series we're not
talking about electricity moving through circuits, we're talking about information
moving through circuits.
And once again for us, they will always be acyclic, where the information
moves from left to right.
Here's a different example of
a different type of circuit called an arithmetic circuit.
This time the wires store numbers and the gates represent
arithmetic operations such as addition and multiplication.
Here you can see an example
of an arithmetic circuit.
It's not important for the sake
of this lesson what it does, it's just an example that's
meant to convey the idea that there are different
notions of circuits.
We can also think about
circuits involving randomness, for instance, where the gates represent
probabilistic operations, and if you felt like it,
you could probably sit around all day dreaming up new models of computation based on the notion of circuits.
In the quantum circuit model,
the wires represent Qubits, and the gates represent both unitary operations and measurements.
Here's a very simple example
of a quantum circuit.
There's just one Qubit in this circuit, which is represented
by the horizontal line, and the gates, which are
indicated by squares,
represent unitary operations that are performed on this Qubit.
So there are no measurements
in this particular example.
If we want to give the
Qubit a name such as X, we can indicate that in the diagram by putting an X right
here, that's optional.
Just like we had for the Boolean circuit from a few moments ago, we can think about this circuit
as representing a sequence of operations where time
goes from left to right.
So we start out with X,
we apply the first gate, which is a Hadamard gate
followed by an S gate,
then another Hadamard
gate, and finally a T gate.
We saw these operations
toward the end of lesson one, and here you can see
their matrix descriptions.
So when we perform these
four operations in order, which means first H, then
S, then H again, and then T,
the combined operation is given
by this product right here, keeping in mind that the order
essentially gets reversed
as we talked about in lesson one. If we perform the matrix multiplication, we get this matrix right here,
and so the action of the
circuit on the Qubit X is described by this unitary matrix.
Sometimes we'd like to indicate explicitly in a quantum circuit diagram
what input we're feeding in, and we can do that as you see right here.
In this case, we're inputting
Ket 0 into the circuit.
That's pretty common. We often take Ket 0 to
be the initialized state of a Qubit, but that's not necessary.
We could also consider
applying the circuit to a different state.
If we choose to, we can also
indicate the output state that we get like this.
Here's another example where
this time we have two Qubits named X and Y as you
can see in the diagram.
Here we have a Hadamard gate, which is being applied to the Qubit Y, followed by the gate that's indicated by
this symbol right here,
which is a Controlled NOT gate. We talked about the
Controlled NOT operation in the previous lesson,
and here in this diagram we
can see that the control Qubit is Y, which is indicated by
the small filled in circle,
and the target Qubit is X, which is indicated by the large circle with what looks like a plus sign in it.
It kind of looks like the
symbol for the exclusive OR so it makes sense.
You can imagine that whatever
classical state is stored in Y gets XOR'd onto the Qubit X.
And just in the interest of clarity, here's the diagram that
shows the action of this gate on standard basis states,
where we assume the A
and B are binary values.
For other states, the action is determined
by linearity as always.
Now, before we go any further, it will be helpful to
explicitly state a convention that we're going to follow concerning how Qubits are ordered
in quantum circuit diagrams like this one.
And the convention is that
bottom to top ordering in a quantum circuit diagram is equivalent to left to right ordering
as in a tuple or a tensor product.
That's a convention we'll
follow in the series and it's also the convention
that's used in Qiskit.
So for this particular circuit right here, we're thinking about it as
acting on a pair of Qubits X, Y,
X comes first because it's on the bottom, and Y comes last or second in this case, because it's on the top.
The way you can think about
this visually, in case it helps, is to imagine rotating
this circuit clockwise so that the inputs are on the top
and the outputs are on the bottom, and the ordering of the
Qubits will be correct.
Sometimes this ordering trips people up, so just be sure to keep
this convention in mind.
So when we think about the action that this circuit describes, what we have first is a
Hadamard gate applied to Y
and then a Controlled NOT
gate on the two Qubits with Y being the control
and X being the target.
If we wanna write down a unitary matrix that describes the combined
action of these two gates, we can do that.
First, we consider the Hadamard gate on Y.
We're applying the Hadamard gate to Y and doing nothing to X, which is equivalent to
performing an identity operation on X.
And so the action of the Hadamard gate on both Qubits together is
given by the tensor product of the identity matrix and
the matrix representing
the Hadamard operation on Y.
That looks like this, keeping in mind our
convention that X comes first and Y comes second, so it's
the identity tensored with H.
Then we apply the
Controlled NOT operation, which has this matrix
representation, and again, that's consistent with our convention.
The second Qubit Y is the control and the first Qubit X is the target.
Don't be afraid to pause the video and verify that this makes sense and I'll stop reminding you about that.
You can pause these videos, go back and watch parts
as many times as you want, adjust the playback speed if you choose, use them in whatever
way works best for you.
Anyway, when we compose the
two operations together, the combined action is described
by this product right here,
and these two matrices are
multiplied in this order because the Hadamard is performed first and the Controlled NOT
is performed second,
and once again, this is consistent
with what we talked about in lesson one where the ordering
essentially gets reversed.
If we perform the matrix multiplication, we get this matrix right here.
And we can now read off from this matrix what the circuit does to
standard basis states.
If we run the circuit on the input 0, 0, meaning Ket 0 for the first Qubit, Ket 0 for the second Qubit,
the result is the Phi+ Bell state, which we can see from the
first column of the matrix.
If we feed in 0, 1, we get the Phi- state, one zero gives us the Si+ state,
and 1, 1 gives us not Psi-, but -1 X Psi-.
The minus sign isn't
really significant here. If you didn't want this to be here, you could perform a swap
operation on the two Qubits
to get rid of it and you
wouldn't mess up what happened to the first three standard basis states.
But it's really not important
for the sake of this example.
So in summary, the circuit has this action right here on standard basis states.
When you're thinking about
what a particular circuit does, you don't need to go through
the conversion to matrices and multiply them together,
you can also trace through the
action that the circuit has on particular states, and in many cases this will
be the preferred option.
In this example, for instance, we can see what the circuit
does to the 0, 0 state by examining the action of the gates.
The initial state, which
we've named Pi zero here, just to avoid a name
that would be confusing with the Bell states is 0, 0.
We apply the Hadamard gate and the state we get is 0+ which we can expand out like this,
and then the Controlled NOT operation takes this state to the Phi+ state, which we can see by thinking
about the action that the Controlled NOT has on
standard basis states,
And you can do the same
thing for the other three standard basis states or any
other state for that matter.
We can also incorporate classical bits into quantum circuit diagrams.
They're indicated by
double lines like you see in this diagram.
That is A and B are classical bits and X and Y are Qubits.
We have the same two unitary gates as in the previous example, and these symbols right here represent standard basis measurements
Specifically after the two
unitary operations are performed, a standard basis measurement
is performed on Y
and the result is overwritten
to the classical bit, B, and similarly X is measured and the result is written to the bit A.
Here you can see that the Qubits X and Y continue on after they're measured.
It's pretty common
though that we don't care all that much about Qubits
after they're measured.
Sometimes all we care about
is the measurement result. And in a case like that, we can use the shorthand
style that you see here
where measurements have Qubits coming in and classical bits coming out.
The understanding here is that
once the Qubits are measured, they're just discarded or ignored and the classical measurement
outcome is carried forward.
Now as the series continues, we'll be seeing many
examples of quantum circuits and they'll typically
be much more complicated than the very simple
examples that we just saw.
As I mentioned earlier, different symbols are
used for different gates.
Single cubic gates are usually
just written as squares with a letter indicating
which operation it is.
Sometimes these different
gates are color coded to mean different things, but
we'll ignore that for now.
We've already seen the
Controlled NOT gate.
Swap gates are denoted
as you see right here, And Toffoli gates and Fredkin gates
are denoted as you see right here.
Remember that a Toffoli gate is a controlled Controlled NOT gate and a Fredkin gate is
a controlled swap gate.
So these symbols are
consistent with the idea that a control Qubit is
indicated by a solid circle with a line connecting it
to the gate it controls.
In general, controlled Qubits
don't need to be on the top and these gates don't have
to act on neighboring Qubits, meaning that these gates
can be stretched across
other Qubits that they don't act on, and we'll see that
happening in future lessons.
One more thing that we often do when using the quantum circuit model is to view arbitrary unitary operations
on any number of Qubits
as if they're single gates like you see right here.
Just by drawing a rectangle with a label corresponding
to whatever unitary operation it is.
In this case it's some
unitary operation U.
Of course, we don't know
what U is from this diagram, we have to assume that
U is defined somehow or that we're considering some arbitrary
unitary operation U, perhaps. It could be for example that
we just wanna think about U as if it's a subroutine in
the interest of clarity.
We also use this notation
that you see right here for a controlled U operation
where the control Qubit is indicated by a solid circle
just like we had before.
So that's a brief introduction
to the quantum circuit model. And as I said before, we will see many more
examples of quantum circuits
as we continue on in the series.
In the next part of the lesson, we're going to take a
look at inner products, orthonormality and projections, which are very important notions
in quantum information and computation.
We'll start with inner products.
Remember that when we
use the direct notation, a Ket is a column vector
and a Bra is a row vector,
and specifically the
Bra vector corresponding to a given column vector is the conjugate transpose
of that column vector.
So for this vector right here, we obtain the corresponding Bra vector by transposing the vector
as if it's a matrix,
which amounts to laying it on its side and then taking the complex conjugate of each of the entries.
Now, suppose that we have two Kets with the same number of entries like this.
If we form this bracket right here, which simply means that
we take the product of the Bra and the Ket,
as if they're matrices,
then we obtain this expression
that you see right here, which is a scaler, or in
other words a complex number.
This value is called the inner
product of these two vectors.
You can also think about inner products in terms of vectors of the
form that you see right here where the vectors are expressed
as linear combinations
of standard basis vectors.
The inner product of these vectors is defined in the same way as
before, Bra Psi times Ket Phi which we can express
as a product like this.
And if we compute and simplify, we're left with this expression right here for the inner product, which is analogous to what we had before,
except this time we're
taking the sum over elements in our classical state set, which is sigma in this particular case.
Here's an example that's meant to give you a geometric picture for
how inner products work.
Here I've drawn a circle
in a two-dimensional space corresponding to a Qubit, and as long as we restrict our attention
to vectors having real number entries, we can draw them as points on this plane.
Let's take Phi to be
this vector right here.
It's a unit vector, which we can see by
computing the Euclidean norm and that's what this circle represents,
it's all of the unit vectors
having real number entries.
Let's also say Psi to be
this vector right here, which again is also a unit vector.
It's the minus state in fact, but here we're just calling it Psi.
If we compute the inner
product of these two vectors, we get one minus the square root of three over two times root two,
which happens to be approximately -1/4.
The value of this inner product is equal to the cosine of the angle
between the two vectors, which you can see here in the figure.
That's something that's
generally true for unit vectors. If we have two unit vectors and they both have real number entries,
then the inner product between them is equal to the cosine of
the angle between them.
In particular, if the inner
product is equal to zero, like in this example, where we've changed Psi to
be this state right here,
then the two vectors must
be at a 90 degree angle to one another.
This all generalizes to
vectors in any dimension, by the way, as long as the
entries are real numbers, it's not just for two dimensional vectors.
If we have complex number entries, the picture doesn't really
work anymore, but nevertheless, the inner product is every
bit as useful as we will see.
The inner product has some
very important properties and we'll take a few moments to observe some of those properties now.
First is a connection
between the inner product and the Euclidean norm.
If we take the inner product
of any vector with itself, we get the Euclidean norm squared.
So we can alternatively say that the Euclidean norm of a vector is equal to the square
root of the inner product
of that vector with itself. This isn't a coincidence, this
is a fundamental connection, and here we can see that if we didn't have
the complex conjugates in the definition of the inner product, then this formula
wouldn't be true anymore, and we wouldn't have such a useful notion
with this fundamental connection
to the Euclidean norm.
Next, the inner product
is conjugate symmetric, which means that if we swap
the order of the two arguments, then the value we get for the
inner product gets conjugated.
That's expressed by
this equation right here and is quite straightforward to see why this happens for these two expressions
for the inner product of the two vectors in the two possible orders.
The inner product is linear
in the second argument. Specifically, if we define a vector Phi to be this linear
combination of two vectors,
Phi one and Phi two, then the inner product of
any vector Psi with Phi is the same linear combination
of the two inner products,
and this follows quite
directly from the fact that matrix multiplication is linear.
And we also have that the inner
product is conjugate linear in the first argument, which you can see expressed right here.
If Psi is this linear
combination of vectors, then if we take the inner
product of Psi and Phi,
then Bra Psi becomes this vector that we see right here where we take the complex
conjugate of beta one and beta two,
and so this is the result and that's what's meant
by conjugate linearity.
And the last property of the inner product that I wanna mention is
the incredibly useful Cauchy-Schwarz inequality.
For any two vectors, Psi and Phi, the absolute value of the inner product can never be larger than the
product of the Euclidean norms
of the two vectors. And moreover, the only way that the two
sides of the inequality can be equal is if the two
vectors are linearly dependent,
which means that one of them is equal to some scaler times the other.
This is in fact one of the
most widely used inequality in all of mathematics and
we use it over and over when we're talking about
quantum information,
so it's very good to know about.
Next, we'll talk about the
notions of orthogonality and orthonormality which are
connected with inner products
and specifically, with
inner products of vectors being equal to zero.
To be precise, if we have
two vectors, Psi and Phi, we say that they're orthogonal
if their inner product
is equal to zero. And the way that we can think
about orthogonal vectors intuitively is that they're
at right angles to each other,
or alternatively, that they're
perpendicular to one another.
People sometimes use the term orthogonal to refer to things that have
nothing to do with each other, like saying that one issue
is orthogonal to another,
but that's obviously pretty informal and not really meaningful
in a mathematical sense, but the connection is clear if you think about orthogonal
vectors as pointing
not in opposite directions, but in completely different directions like north versus west for instance.
If we have a set of vectors, we say that the set is an orthogonal set if any two distinct vectors
chosen from that set
are necessarily orthogonal to one another, which we can express
as you see right here,
An orthonormal set is
simply an orthogonal set of unit vectors.
Vectors in orthogonal
sets don't necessarily need to be unit vectors, and in fact you could
even have zero vector
being an element of an orthogonal set, but in an orthonormal set, every vector must be a unit vector
in addition to the
requirement that the set is an orthogonal set.
Given what we know about the relationship between the inner product
and the Euclidean norm, we can express this
condition pretty succinctly
as you see right here.
And finally, an orthonormal basis is simply an orthonormal
set that forms a basis for whatever vector space
we're talking about.
For example, if we take any
classical state set sigma and we think about the set of
all standard basis vectors,
we see that this is an orthonormal set and in fact it's an orthonormal basis for the space of all vectors whose entries correspond to
this classical state set sigma.
These are all unit vectors and
they're orthogonal in pairs, so it's an orthonormal set.
and because it's a basis as well, we have that it's an orthonormal basis.
Orthonormal sets are
always linearly independent by the way, so anytime you
have an orthonormal set, it will always be an orthonormal
basis for some subspace,
but in this case, we have a basis for the entire space that we're working with.
Another example is the set
containing Ket+ and Ket-.
These two vectors are orthogonal, their inner product is equal to zero.
and they're both unit vectors and they span the
two-dimensional space of vector corresponding to a single Qubit, so they form an orthonormal
basis for that space.
Another example is the Bell basis, which is an orthonormal basis for the space of all
four dimensional vectors corresponding to two Qubits.
The set containing Ket 0
and Ket+ on the other hand, is not an orthogonal set because the inner product between
these vectors is non-zero.
They're both unit vectors and this is a basis for the vector space corresponding to a Qubit, but we don't have orthogonality.
Here's a handy fact about orthonormal sets that we'll make use of from time to time.
Suppose that we have some
orthonormal set of vectors, specifically, let's suppose
that we have M vectors in this set, Psi one through Psi M,
where we're assuming that these vectors are drawn from some N
dimensional vector space, or in other words, each of
the vectors has M entries.
As I already mentioned, orthonormal sets are always
linearly independent, so it can't be that M is larger than N,
but it could be that M is smaller than N, and that's the case that
we're interested in.
And what the fact states is
that if M is smaller than N, then it's always possible
to add additional vectors
to the set we started with in order to obtain an
orthonormal basis for our space.
To be precise, there must
necessarily exist vectors Psi M+1 up to Psi N so that the entire collection
forms an orthonormal basis.
So you can never paint yourself
into a corner, so to speak, by somehow choosing an
orthonormal set of vectors that can't be extended to
form an orthonormal basis.
Sometimes you can just look
at the set you start with and figure out how to extend it to form an orthonormal basis, but an alternative that always works
is to use a procedure known as the Gram-Schmidt
orthonormalization process to construct these vectors.
I won't explain that
procedure in this lesson or in this series because the specifics aren't
really important for us, but of course you can look
it up if you're curious.
It's something that can
be performed by a computer in case that's relevant, so
there's no creativity involved, it's just a mechanical procedure.
One of the reasons why this
is such a handy fact to have is concerned with a close connection that exists between orthonormal
bases and unitary matrices.
In particular, for any square matrix U, the three conditions that you see here are always equivalent,
meaning that they're either
all true or they're all false.
The first condition says
that U is a unitary matrix, which means that both U dagger times U and U times U dagger are both
equal to the identity matrix.
The second condition
says that the rows of U form an orthonormal basis
and the third condition says that the columns of U
form an orthonormal basis.
It's actually not too hard
to see why this equivalence is true.
Just to keep things simple, let's take a look at a
three by three matrix U as you see right here, where the entries can be any
complex numbers you like.
Here on the left hand side I've written U conjugate transposed
just for convenience.
If we form three vectors
from the columns of U, which here are named Psi
one, Psi two and Psi three, then if we take the
product of U dagger and U,
you can check that each
entry of the product is given by an inner product of vectors as we see right here in this pattern.
And now when you think about the condition that U is unitary, which is equivalent to this matrix being equal to the identity matrix,
you see that it's equivalent
to the three vectors forming an orthonormal set.
The diagonal entries all
have to be equal to one, so these are necessarily unit vectors, and the off diagonal
entries have to be zero,
so it's an orthogonal set of vectors.
So U being unitary is equivalent to the columns forming an orthonormal set,
And that has to be a basis because the number of vectors in the set, which is three in this case, agrees with the dimension of the space
that we're working in. You can follow a similar argument for the rows instead of the columns to conclude that U being
unitary is equivalent
to the rows farming an orthonormal basis.
It doesn't work quite as nicely because we have to make an adjustment to get the complex conjugates
to work in the right way, but the idea is the same.
An alternative way to go about it, which is pretty straightforward, is to prove that a matrix is unitary if and only if it's transposed as unitary.
And here I do mean to say transpose and not conjugate transpose.
It's pretty trivial from the
definition of unitary matrices, that the conjugate transpose
of any unitary matrix is unitary,
but it's also the case that the transpose of any unitary matrix is unitary.
In any case, we have the
equivalence between these three conditions on any square matrix U, and we can combine this equivalence
with the fact about
extending orthonormal sets to form orthonormal bases in order to come up with unitary matrices
that do interesting things
or fulfill various needs that we may encounter.
Specifically anytime we
have an orthonormal set of M vectors, there will always exist a unitary matrix U
whose first M columns are the vectors from that orthonormal set.
The remaining columns
can always be filled in so that we obtain a unitary matrix by choosing them so that the columns form
an orthonormal basis. This will be a pretty
handy fact for us to have at our disposal.
And one more topic for
this section of the lesson is the notion of a projection.
A square matrix Pi is
said to be a projection or a projection matrix if the two properties that
are listed here are both true.
This is a capital Pi by the way, it's a pretty typical choice for a letter that's used to denote a projection.
We often give these typical sorts of names to objects such as matrices just to make them easier to recognize and keep things straight,
but you could use whatever name you like. Anyway, the first condition is that Pi is equal to its own conjugate transpose.
In general, when we have a matrix that's equal to its own
conjugate transpose, we say that it's a Hermitian matrix.
So the first condition can alternatively be stated as Pi is Hermitian.
The second condition is
that if we square Pi, meaning that we multiply Pi
to itself, we get Pi again.
So squaring Pi doesn't do anything to it.
The idea of a projection
intuitively speaking is that it's similar in
spirit to projecting an image onto a screen or dropping
a perpendicular onto a line
for instance. When you multiply a
vector by a projection, what you're doing is in some sense
leaving a part of it alone
and zeroing out the rest.
So if you apply a
projection a second time, it doesn't do anything because
you've already zeroed out the part that the projection zeroes out.
An example of a projection
is this matrix right here for any choice of a unit vector Psi.
We can check that it satisfies
the required conditions one at a time.
For the first one, we compute
the conjugate transpose and this is the conjugate
transpose of a product.
And so we can use this formula right here for the conjugate transpose
of a product to help us.
What you get is the product
of the conjugate transposes, but the order gets reversed.
That happens because of
the transposition part.
So if we apply that formula, we obtain this equality right here and we can then simplify to
get back the original matrix.
Notice by the way, that we didn't use the fact
that Psi is a unit vector.
So in fact, this matrix is
Hermitian for any vector Psi, not just for unit vectors.
And for the second one, we square Pi and we obtain
this expression right here and that is equal to the
original matrix this time
because Psi is a unit vector, so this inner product
right here is equal to one and that's where the assumption
that Psi is a unit vector
comes into play.
We can generalize this example and start with an orthonormal set.
And if we form this matrix right here, where we sum up the projections corresponding to the individual vectors, then we obtain a projection.
Here on the screen, you can see calculations that reveal that and I'll leave it to you to
examine them if you wish.
And along similar lines
to the first example, it's the second condition where the orthonormality
of the set gets used.
What this projection does if
you multiply it to a vector, is to project that
vector onto the subspace that's spanned by this set of vectors,
which in an abstract way is
like dropping a perpendicular to that subspace, and once
you're in that subspace, the projection doesn't do anything.
So matrices like this are
examples of projections, and now in fact we've exhausted
all of the possibilities.
Every projection matrix takes this form for some choice of an orthonormal set.
The zero matrix is a projection, so we do have to make
sure we include that one if we want to get every projection.
So just to be clear about this, we are allowing the
possibility that M equals zero and that gives us an empty sum,
which we can interpret as the zero matrix.
Now that we have the
concept of a projection at our disposal, we can define a more general
class of quantum measurements known as projective measurements.
This isn't the most general
notion of a measurement, but it is significantly more general than standard basis measurements
and it's going to be very
helpful to incorporate it into our description
of quantum information.
A projective measurement is defined by any set of projections
that satisfies the condition that you see right here, which is that the projections
sum to the identity matrix.
Here M can be any
positive integer you like so long as these are all projections and this condition is true,
the collection defines a
projective measurement.
The measurement described
by such a collection works as follows when you
measure any quantum state Psi.
First you get an outcome
between one and M, where M is the number of projections.
For each possible outcome, K, the probability to get that outcome is the Euclidean norm
squared of the vector you get
by multiplying S by Pi
K, the Kth projection.
We can also write this
quantity as you see right here.
This equality comes from the relationship between the Euclidean
norm and the inner product together with the fact
that Pi K is a projection.
From the second form, together with the condition that we have on these projections, we can see right away, by linearity, that our probabilities
will always sum to one,
keeping in mind that Psi
has to be a unit vector.
And second, assuming that
we get the outcome, K, the state of the system
collapses to the quantum state we get by normalizing whatever
vector we got by projecting.
We'll take a look at some
examples in just a moment, but before we do that, let me mention that we don't actually need
to number the possible
outcomes from one to M. We can choose whatever names or symbols we want for the outcomes.
In particular, if we have a collection of projections that are labeled with symbols
from sum set gamma say,
and they satisfy the
same condition as before, which is that they sum
to the identity matrix, then we have a projective measurement
that works in exactly
the same way as before.
The only only difference here is that we're allowing
the measurement outcomes to be elements of this set gamma as opposed to the integers from one to M.
For our first example of
a projective measurement, let's observe that
standard basis measurements are projective measurements.
In this case the set of
outcomes of the measurement is the same as the set of classical states of whatever system is being measured.
And the set of projections
that describes the measurement is this collection right here, assuming that sigma is
the classical state set
of our system. These are all projections
and if we sum them up, we get the identity matrix, so it's a valid projective measurement
To see how this works in
a little bit more detail, let's suppose that we
have some arbitrary state that's written in the form
that you see right here.
The probability for the
measurement to yield the outcome A, according to the description
from a moment ago, is this value right here,
which is equal to the
absolute value squared of the corresponding
entry of the vector Psi, which is what we expect.
Conditioned on the outcome being A, the state of the system becomes this, again, according to the
description from a moment ago.
If we simplify, we don't
quite get the state we expect, which is Ket A.
Instead we get Ket A
multiplied by a scaler, and specifically, this is a scaler having
absolute value equal to one,
so it's a complex number
on the unit circle.
This is called a global phase and we'll discuss global phases shortly, but for now in short, this
state is equivalent to Ket A.
This global phase doesn't
actually have any significance at all and we'll see why
when we get to the discussion of global phases.
So (unclear) this issue of global phases, which we'll talk about in just a moment, we see that standard basis measurements
are in fact projective measurements. For another example, which is really an extension
of the previous example,
if we perform a standard basis
measurement on a system X and we do nothing to a system Y, just like we talked about
in the previous lesson,
it's completely equivalent
to measuring the system X, Y.
With this projective
measurement right here.
We have these projections corresponding to the classical states of X and we're tensoring with the identity on Y
which reflects the fact that
we're not doing anything to Y.
The description for how
projective measurements work in general tells us
what happens in this example, and I'll leave it to you to
check that this is in fact
completely equivalent to what we discussed in the previous lesson.
This is all very nice because this projective
measurement description is cleaner in a way and we see that it fits into
this more general picture.
Here's one more example of
a projective measurement.
This one is a measurement of two Qubits.
For this measurement
we have two projections and therefore, two possible
outcomes which are zero and one.
The projections are defined
in terms of the Bell states as you see right here.
The first projection is
onto the space spanned by the three symmetric Bell states and the second projection is
onto the one dimensional space
spanned by the Psi- state, which is the anti-symmetric one, or in other words the
one that gets multiplied
by a minus sign if we
perform a swap operation on the two Qubits.
We'll see later on in the series why this is an interesting measurement.
For now, it's just an example
that connects with something that we've seen before,
which is the Bell basis.
One final note on projective measurements is that anytime you have
a projective measurement, you can always implement that measurement
using unitary operations and
standard basis measurements.
For this particular example of
a measurement, for instance, we can build a quantum circuit that implements the measurement
as you see right here.
We imagine that the top
two Qubits are the Qubits that we're measuring with
this projective measurement and what we can do is
introduce a new Qubit
that starts off initialized
to the zero state. We perform a Hadamard gate
followed by a Fredkin gate, followed by another Hadamard gate,
and if we measure this bottom Qubit using a standard basis measurement, the effect will be exactly the same as if we've measured the top two Qubits
with the projective
measurement from this example.
We'll get exactly the same probabilities for the two outcomes and the effect that the measurement has on the top two Qubits
will be the same as well.
That's not at all obvious. An analysis is required to see that and that analysis isn't shown here.
As I've already suggested, we will take a closer look at
this particular measurement in a later lesson and for now
it's just meant as an example.
The important point to take away is that something like
this is always possible for any projective measurement, so we don't really gain
any additional capabilities
by introducing projective measurements, but it is a very useful concept and we will often speak
of projective measurements
as we continue on in the series. The last part of this lesson is on a few important limitations
of quantum information
and what we can do with quantum circuits.
The first limitation, which maybe isn't so much of a limitation as it is degeneracy, concerns the issue of global phases
that I mentioned a short time ago. Here's the definition of what we mean when we refer to a global phase.
If we have two quantum
state vectors, Psi and Phi, such that one of them is
equal to the other one multiplied by some complex number alpha,
then we say that the states
differ by a global phase or alternatively that they're equivalent up to a global phase.
Notice that because quantum state vectors have Euclidean norm equal to one, the only way that this
equation can possibly be true
is if the absolute value
of this complex number is equal to one, so alpha
must lie on the unit circle.
Let's imagine that we have
two quantum states like this that differ by a global phase and suppose that we measure the state Phi
with a standard basis measurement.
The probability to get any outcome A is given by this expression right here, and if we substitute
alpha times Psi for Phi,
which we can do because we're
assuming that they're equal, we obtain this probability.
And if we simplify using the fact that alpha lies in the
complex unit circle, we obtain this probability.
Remember that this is the probability that measuring Phi gives the outcome A, but now we see that
this is exactly the same as the probability that measuring
Psi gives the outcome A,
so there's absolutely
no difference whatsoever in the probabilities of different outcomes for the two states.
A similar argument tells us more generally that for any projective measurement, the probabilities are again identical.
So by measuring we can't
tell the difference between two states that
differ by a global phase, even in a statistical sense.
Finally, if we apply any unitary
operation to the state Phi, then again by substituting, what we will get is exactly
the same complex number alpha
multiplied to whatever we will get by applying the same unitary
operation to the state, Psi.
So the two states will still
differ by a global phase.
The bottom line is that the two states are completely indistinguishable, so there's really no
difference between them at all
in terms of what we could
possibly learn about them from performing unitary
operations and measurements and for this reason,
we consider these two
states to be equivalent or if you prefer, that these are just two possibly different
vector representations of
the same quantum state.
Like I said at the
start of the discussion, it's basically degeneracy
in how quantum states are described by quantum state vectors.
In any case, what this means is that we can
simply ignore global phases just like we did effectively when we describe standard
basis measurements
as projective measurements. By the way, this degeneracy only happens in the simplified description
of quantum information.
When we describe quantum
states using density matrices, as we will do in the
third unit of the series, we will have a unique
matrix representation
for every quantum state. The issue of global phases
simply doesn't arise in the general description
of quantum information.
It's one more appealing aspect
of the general description of quantum information,
which I keep alluding to, but regardless, global
phases won't bother us
because we can just exercise
our freedom to ignore them.
Here's a very quick
example just to make sure the notion of a global phase is clear.
If we have a minus state, and negative one times a minus state, then these two states
differ by a global phase, and in particular we have
alpha equals negative one.
On the other hand, if we have a plus state and a minus state, then we don't have two states
that differ by a global phase.
These are orthogonal vectors, so they're linearly independent.
To say that two quantum state vectors differ by a global phase
is equivalent to saying that the vectors are linearly dependent,
so certainly these vectors
don't differ by a global phase.
It's true that the only difference is that this plus sign
turns into this minus sign, but that's what we call a
relative phase difference.
That's different from a global phase because we're not
multiplying the entire vector by a complex number.
And this is consistent with the fact that we can tell the difference
between these states, in particular, if we
apply a Hadamard operation
and then measure, we'll see a zero if the
state was a plus state and a one if the state was a minus state.
The next limitation of quantum information that we'll see in this lesson
is the no-cloning theorem.
Here's one statement of
the no-cloning theorem and this particular
statement of the theorem is pretty concrete and specific,
which will make it easier to talk about. There are other more general ways to formulate the no-cloning theorem,
but we'll focus on this one for now.
We assume that we have two systems X and Y which have the same classical state set.
which consists of the
integer from zero to D-1 where D is at least two.
It's not really important what names the classical states have, but by choosing these names it'll help to keep things simple.
What's most important
here is that there are at least two different classical
states, so in other words, we're not worrying about the
trivial and uninteresting case
where we only have one classical state.
What the theorem says is that there's no unitary operation U that we can apply to X, Y so that if we initialize
Y to the zero state,
we effectively copy or clone
arbitrary quantum states of X.
If we take a look at this
expression right here in isolation, what it says is that for all choices of a quantum state vector Psi of X,
applying U to Psi tensored
with the zero state, gives us Psi tensor Psi, or in other words two
independent copies of Psi,
so that's what it would mean if we could clone quantum
states and what the theorem says is that this is not possible.
You can think about this
in terms of circuits and what the theorem says is
that you'll never be able to come up with a gate or a circuit
that works as you see here.
Where one copy of the state Psi comes in along with a collection
of initialized Qubits and two copies of Psi are produced.
You can do this for certain
choices of the state Psi, but you can never come up with
a circuit that works this way for every quantum state Psi,
and that's what the theorem says.
It's quite easy to prove
this theorem, in fact, it essentially boils down to the fact that the transformation we're
looking for isn't linear,
but unitary operations are
linear, so it just can't work.
Here's an argument in a bit more detail.
Suppose that we have a unitary operation U that clones the standard basis
states, Ket 0 and Ket one.
We know that the classical
states zero and one must belong to our classical state set because D is at least two.
But this means by linearity
that if X is in a plus state, which we can write like this,
then the result is this linear combination of these two states right here.
However, that's not the right behavior. The requirement on U is that
U cloned is a plus state,
which means that we have to
have this equation right here being satisfied.
These two states aren't the
same and so it doesn't work and that's all there is to it.
Just a few additional remarks
about the no-cloning theorem.
First, this statement of the
no-cloning theorem is absolute in some sense.
It simply says that a unitary operation U that works exactly like
this doesn't exist.
So you might ask whether
or not there exists unitary operation U that
does this approximately with respect to some way of describing
an approximation to the statement. There are different
notions of approximation that one might be interested in
and we'll see a couple
of them in the third unit of the series, but for these different
notions of approximation,
there are quantitative statements
of the no-cloning theorem that put strong limits on how well you can approximately clone.
A second remark is that copying or cloning standard basis states most
certainly is possible.
For example, a Controlled NOT gate copies the standard basis states of a Qubit.
This doesn't contradict
the no-cloning theorem. The point is that cloning in the sense of the no-cloning theorem requires
that this works not only
for standard basis states
but for all states.
A Controlled NOT gate
certainly doesn't clone a plus state for instance.
And finally, it is worth pointing out that there's also a no-cloning theorem for
probabilistic states.
It's just not something
that people talk about or care about.
If somebody randomly
chooses a bit, for instance, for some arbitrary way of
assigning probabilities to the two values and
then hands you that bit,
of course there's no way for you to obtain two independent samples
of that random bit.
You just don't know what
the probabilities are.
You can copy the bit just like a Controlled NOT
copies standard basis states, but that's not the same thing as cloning the probabilistic state.
You just don't have enough
information to do that. Whatever random bit you were given doesn't tell you what
the probabilities were.
It's just a bit.
The impossibility of cloning
a probabilistic state follows from exactly the same reasoning as in the quantum setting.
Cloning is a non-linear process, whereas probabilistic operations, just like unitary operations, are linear.
Anyway, it's not surprising
that we can't clone on a probabilistic state and
somehow it's not as interesting as the fact that we can't
clone a quantum state,
but the point is simply to observe that this is not a uniquely
quantum phenomenon.
The final limitation
of quantum information that we'll discuss in this lesson is that it's not possible
to perfectly discriminate
two quantum states that aren't orthogonal.
Another way of saying this
is that if two quantum states can be perfectly discriminated, then they have to be orthogonal.
What we mean when we refer
to a perfect discrimination of two quantum states, Psi and Phi, is that there's some
way to tell them apart
without any chance of error.
In terms of the quantum circuit model, we can express this as you
see here on the screen.
We have some unitary operation U, which could be implemented
as a quantum circuit or we could just think about U abstractly
as a unitary operation
and force input U takes either the state Psi or the state Phi
along with a bunch of initialized Qubits, which you can think of as workspace Qubits that somehow assist in this
process of discrimination.
After U as applied, the top Qubit is measured with respect to a standard basis measurement and here's the perfect
discrimination part.
If the input state was Psi, then the measurement must
give the outcome zero, 100% of the time, and if
the input state was Phi,
then the measurement must
give the outcome one, again with 100% chance.
It's not important what the
states of these other Qubits are after U was applied.
All that matters is this one bit that we get from the measurement because that's the bit that's telling us which of the two states we started with.
For some choices of states, Psi and Phi, it will be possible to perform a perfect discrimination like
this and for others it won't.
And what we'll observe is that
if it is possible to do this, then Psi and Phi have
to be orthogonal states
and that means if Phi and
Psi are not orthogonal, you can't perfectly discriminate them.
So let's see why a perfect discrimination implies orthogonality.
We'll start by writing down two equations that express what these
two diagrams express.
If we think about the quantum state, we get after applying U to a
bunch of initialized Qubits together with the state Psi,
we see that it has to
have this form right here, where Pi zero is some quantum state vector representing the state
of all of these Qubits
except for the top one. We don't have any information
about this quantum state, Pi zero, it could be anything,
but we know that the entire
state has to look like this because that's the only
way that the measurement is guaranteed to give the
outcome zero, 100% of the time.
And we have an analogous
equation for the second one.
This time the top Qubit
has to be in the one state and similar to Pi zero, the
state Pi one could be anything.
And in addition to having
no information about Pi one, we also don't know anything
about the relationship between Pi zero and Pi one.
For all we know, these are just two
arbitrary quantum states.
What we can do next is
to multiply both sides of these equations on
both sides by U dagger, meaning the conjugate transpose of U.
And if we do that, we get the two equations
that you see right here.
We're using the fact that U dagger times U is the identity matrix.
So that's why we don't see U or U dagger on the left hand side of either equation.
And now we can consider the inner product between Psi and Phi.
It's the same as the inner
product of Psi and Phi multiplied to the inner
product of the L zero state with itself
because the inner product of
any state with itself is one and that includes the L zero state.
And now if we look at our two equations, we see that this expression here is equal to the inner product of the vectors
represented by the two equations. And in particular it's the inner product between the left hand
sides of these equations.
So we can equally well
express this inner product as the inner product of the vectors represented by the right hand
sides of these equations,
because the left hand side is
equal to the right hand side for both equations.
So we get this expression right here, which is the inner product
of the two right hand sides of the equations or equivalently,
it's the conjugate transpose of the first multiplied to the second.
U times U dagger is equal
to the identity matrix, because U is unitary and so it goes away.
And we can simplify just a little bit to get the product of
these inner products.
Now remember that we don't know anything about the relationship
between Pi zero and Pi one, so we don't know what
their inner product is.
That's a mystery to us. But whatever it is, we're multiplying it to the inner product of Ket 0 and Ket one, which is zero.
So the end result is that
we obtain the value zero, but that's what we wanted to show, the inner product between
Psi and Phi is equal to zero.
So the two states are orthogonal.
So don't bother trying
to perfectly discriminate two non-orthogonal quantum
states, you just can't do it.
There is a converse to the
statement that we just proved, which is that orthogonal quantum states always can be perfectly discriminated,
and this is not too hard to
see if we make use of a fact that I mentioned earlier in the lesson.
Specifically if Psi and
Phi are orthogonal states, then one thing that we can do is to choose any unitary matrix U
whose first two columns
are the two states.
We know that it's always
possible to do this and it doesn't matter
for the sake of this task exactly how this unitary matrix is chosen.
All that's important is that these are the first two columns.
We don't need any additional Qubits. If we simply apply U to
the two possible states, then we'll get these
two possible outcomes.
And if we measure the top most Qubit, which remember is the right most Qubit, then we'll get a zero or a one
depending on which state we started with.
Alternatively, we can consider
a projective measurement with outcomes zero to one
defined as you see right here.
in this case, the measurement
actually only depends on Psi.
This measurement perfectly
discriminates Psi from any state that's orthogonal to Psi.
If we measure Psi with respect to this projective measurement, then we'll get the outcome
zero with probability one as these equations review.
And for any state Phi
that's orthogonal to Psi, we'll get the outcome
one with probability one.
I won't go through the
details of these calculations, but if you're interested, I encourage you to go through
the details on your own.
And that is the end of lesson three. We covered a lot of
material in this lesson, including quantum circuits,
inner products and orthonormality, projections and projective measurements, the fact that global phases don't matter,
the no-cloning theorem, and the fact that non-orthogonal states can't be perfectly discriminated while orthogonal states can.
I hope you'll join me for
the fourth lesson soon, which is the last lesson in
the first unit of the series.
In the fourth lesson, we'll talk about three
very important examples, teleportation, superdense coding,
and the CHSH inequality or CHSH game as it's sometimes described.
Goodbye until then,